oui regardez ça va ressembler à ça mais
d'abord on va laisser le vrai le chef
stéphane malterre et son élève
oscar chartier
aujourd'hui avec oscar nous vous
proposons une recette à base de saumon
d'avocats d'oignons rouges
on aura une petite patte habenis on va
faire cuire quelques blinis et puis
oscars va vous commencez par vous
présenter la façon de lever les pavés de
saumon
on retire un petit peu de peau pour
pouvoir tenir après le
le poisson voilà et utilise qu'elle
coûte oscar j'utilise un filet de sole
c'est un couteau sous pour bien pouvoir
passer soit c'est sous le saumon en asie
en inclinant la type e là l'homme sur la
peau d'où l'important c'est de ne pas
laisser de saumon sur la poésie voilà ce
que ça donne
voilà je prends ton ami en rouge
je vais couper en petites lamelles et
après dans l'autre sens à faire des
petits milles très bien
[Musique]
on va faire un fond d'avocats d'accord
de temps qu on a découpé l'avocat en
gros dés de cette fois senti donc voilà
donc tu as mis quoi dans ton assiette à
la hausse car un petit peu de poivre de
fleur de sel et des graines de pavot
pour décorer l'assiette
[Musique]
suite je vais mettre de l'oignon rouge
précisé tout à l'heure
[Musique]
donc je vous ai pas précisé mais le
saumon l'a fait mariner avec une petite
vinaigrette à base de vinaigre d'orléans
voilà la maison martin pourrait des
dernières maisons à fabriquer du
vinaigre sur orléans
ensuite oscars et ensuite je vais
prendre notre saumon mariné que je vais
mettre sur la préparation j'ai
[Musique]
et pendant ce temps là moi je vais
préparer quelques petits blêmissent
oscars oui d'accord c'est une sorte de
pâte à crêpes dans laquelle on ajoute de
la levure chimique et on monte des
blancs en neige pour alléger la pâte
directement sur la crêpière je dépose un
petit rond de pâte
[Musique]
dressage je vais y ajouter un petit
bouquet de deux salades
et des petites graines de pavot pour
l'esthétique aussi
[Musique]
donc il faut cuire à une température
assez élevée à les médecins pour mettre
le feu très vif
voilà et après qu'est ce qu'on en fait
nous bénisse et ensuite on va les mettre
sur l'assiette pour pouvoir après les
déguster avec le saumon
jean mais combien ont nommé 3 mais on
tour m 4 oui boinet temps à 4 les
médicale
voilà
dans votre assiette du coup quatre plis
ni dans la mienne lui en a trois il y en
a pour tout le monde nous voilà et bah
y'a plus qu'à déguster